hey yo welcome back to Blood Bowl this
is Kauai this is Chung my character and
this is my wife my wife I like to smack
that booty just like I do here and these
are our baby children there would be no
food for later I go hood all right i'ma
go hey get with the phone you do with
soul ice episode we kill the [ __ ]
good chimes oh hey you got a nice hey I
want that hey I miss I'm dead I'm dead
now I'm being silly right now so silly
awful foxy
well now I'm not so silly no mo it's
gonna be a long laborious it's gonna be
a long day here yeah forbidden words
that's a nice wing of [ __ ] sake what is
this place it's so mysterious it reminds
me of Dark Souls and Dark Souls 2 at the
same time Oh a light let there be light
my children hey daddy are you doing oh
my god ah I just randomly jump Jesus
Christ what an epic dodge oh my god oh
god I hear a lot of noise Oh God my
favorite
I sent them boats shut up you're asleep
this guy looks like he wants to be
fisted io fished me daddy
who's next
Oh God the [ __ ] just happened oh god
they're cannonballs what the [ __ ] that's
nice cannonball you have there sir hey
hey hey hey hey can I borrow it
ok my turn boom [ __ ] whoops I'm not
very good at it why do I suck I like
this post I have while I'm playing I
might as well sit like this [ __ ] are you
guys doing sorry did you just murder
your family safe havens well I I guess
we tell him about the Odeon chapel
[Music]
well done
don't hit him my wife don't like this
got a really bad feeling about this and
the daddy shall to be fisted oh god he
has so much health look at that
what is he he's [ __ ] dead oh whoa
calm down calm down calm down calm down
calm down calm down calm down everyone
chill oh my [ __ ] god what was died
guess I won't be sleeping tonight guess
I won't be sleeping tonight let's go
deeper inside yay
Fisher she said what the [ __ ] is that I
don't know but we're gonna kill it oh
god oh god there's more oh [ __ ] this
plane but oh my god oh no I never never
did I ask for this what the [ __ ] are you
hey piggy oh my god that food is so nice
but why don't you come in the bath it's
nice and warm for you
come on main we never do anything fun
anymore now what the [ __ ] is that Jesus
Christ what did you buy that hide just
what I wanted to see alright boss battle
then [ __ ] me see if I care
[ __ ] see if I care
[Music]
oh great great more nightmares just what
I wanted
how the [ __ ] does that hit me I fight me
[ __ ] sake one at a time ladies come on
you're a [ __ ] aren't you probably
kill the mage Oh
oh my god suck a dick hey you're [ __ ]
that aren't you yeah that's right bird
Oh who's next
Oh God Oh get harder it's just like real
life oh my god [ __ ] oh my god oh my god
definitely don't want to kill him that's
nice
no no do they release erect what what
the [ __ ] is that
what [ __ ] yeah that's fair
let's do this oh my god that's [ __ ]
that's even more [ __ ] someone you're
sick now okay
I didn't I didn't go so well did it did
it stop that move is not fair that's
cute
oh god no don't die don't die tonight
tonight
don't die don't die are you kidding me
I had that
what the [ __ ] was that almost that oh my
god no [ __ ] hell just kill me then I
didn't actually mean that hi guys so
annoying
oh you're summoned snakes huh oh god I'm
not that I'm not oh oh
yes someone sneaks see if I care about
you and your [ __ ] sneak on my help
oh my god oh my god oh my god I don't
have rolls don't die now don't die now
for the love of dicks in the face oh one
more hit
[Music]